[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
around tonight
[Music]
I use that word destiny San Antonio
Spurs select especially if - now that I
can realize everything that happened
Tony Parker a Racing Club Paris is
almost like everything that happened in
my life prepared me to be the starting
point of this person
my favorite player was Michael Jordan
growing up he's don't want to inspire me
the most my little birdie was like I'm
lefty so my team is dispersed with David
Robinson and so that's how I started
when I got drafted it was finally gonna
happen it was surreal to me to talk to
my brothers that you imagine I'm going
to play with David and we watched him
since we like Tony what are you doing
first arriving at 19 I'm like this guy
is like crazy and I'm never gonna
satisfy him in the beginning his teacher
he shaped him the way he wanted and he
worked out great
it may need even stronger he was able to
handle criticism because I was very
tough on he just took it all in and got
better and better everybody was like a
second father that's for sure you see
them grow as people go through the ups
and downs with you
[Music]
yeah
even if you wanted to write this story I
don't think you start your story with a
little point girl from France issuing
guard from Argentina and a guy from
nylons it's different moments in life
that cinema
I feel lucky that I was part of
something that maybe will never happen
again in the NBA history
blazing fast breakneck speed giving to
the whole creamy shot
- teardrops
I wanted to win for me winning was more
important than having the big galleries
or the big numbers really team sport
[Music]
I was like that's the best chance is to
stay with the Spurs and win a
championship
you have to share you have to sacrifice
the Spurs I think we were the definition
[Music]
every game I have to perform every game
after go to the basket pop was like do
you have to go on the ground every
single time you panic as a pop I don't
do it on purpose anyway that's my game
don't worry I will get off 17 years
after steel penetrator come on the
ground and I will get up and that was my
mentality I was gonna be aggressive
regardless every night
so I feel like I'm lucky kind of because
a lot of athletes they don't know what
they want to do and after basketball
building that Academy and having an
impact on their young generation it's
one of my biggest assists in my career
but you have different opportunities
that you can either do something good
with it or you can just do bad I decided
to do something for others
I always say the Spurs are the best
bands you have to come to San Antonio to
really see how much they love the Spurs
how much they care when you really
different teams it's just nothing
the support with somebody three seconds
to go
I always say my career was better than
the dream because I never dreamt about
getting an NBA champion or being an NBA
all-star MVP of the finals I never
thought that'd be possible for somebody
like me all the sacrifice that we may
grown up it was worth it I was very
close to my brothers I was able to bring
them a lot they came to every playoffs
every NBA Finals for that I'm very
blessed very supportive I really took it
seriously a role of ambassador for
French basketball the best compliment I
can give now I can't go next is my night
pub you're always the boss but on this
night I am
[Laughter]
I know pawpaw you hate you hate when we
talk about you but for me the impact
that you had in my life and I had an
unbelievable dad but you were
unbelievable second dad to me the way
you taught me stuff the way you helped
me understand the game and make me
better
people forget back then there was no
European point guards it was maybe two
three international and then you took a
chance on me you took a chance I will
always remember when I was 19 and you
come in the back end the plane we were
only four games in and say Tony you
gonna start next game and I was like I'm
gonna start did you talk to Jimmy Jimmy
okay with it I was so scared oh there oh
my god I'm starting then thanks for
believing me pop thanks for believing in
me and on the court is one thing poeple
but off the court you're just
unbelievable and you inspire me I try to
do the same thing now with the team that
I own in France and everybody is around
me you taught me a lot and I'll be
thankful forever
thank you very much poeple
[Applause]